this is tea we carry beat Michael make
them famous May 4th in the building
hello everybody good morning good
morning good afternoon if you are in
Europe and beyond good morning good very
early morning west coast you know 6:00
a.m. crew there's a lot of you I
appreciate that
super excited to be on the show hope
everybody had a tremendous weekend and
this is tea with Gary B Dustin's on the
ones and twos always appreciate my man
and let's uh let's get right into it
hi Samantha
how are you I'm well how are you great
thank you so my question is basically
I'm an artist and a big part of what I
do is web comics web comics mostly about
dating I've built my audience on it I've
become known for it and while I love
creating that kind of content I've been
wanting to branch out and share art
about other topics like pieces of my
life but when I do that my engagement
totally plummets so my question is do I
stick with what I'm known and loved for
or do I keep experimenting and branching
out experimenting and branching out in
perpetuity and making it a bigger mix of
your content you know I basically
completely reset in my career when I
switched from Wine Library TV to you
know making business videos that you
know the being a slave to engagement is
a super sad existence yeah I mean just
even the way you're asking the question
I'm like watch it you know you know you
know like you know this is happening to
everybody it really happens to talented
people that are making creative like
yourself it happens to people that love
certain genres it happens to people that
grew up as comics or models you know cuz
they evolved it happens to every child
you know influencer that hits because
who you are at nine is very different
than who you are at sixteen yeah I think
you need a much healthier mix with with
what you want to put out be okay with
the engagement drop the
over a course of three to five years you
know three to six months you'll notice
that you'll start building an audience
for the other stuff I mean when I first
started doing some of the flipping
garage sale stuff it didn't do well now
it's my most performing content like my
garage sale clips I'll perform my
business stuff you know you know I you
might have noticed you know at some
point if you even follow me like a year
and a half ago I just started making
cartoons about the things I believed it
that wasn't you know also at first did
okay and then really got hot so you know
I think you really need to mix in stuff
including like for example I see the
thing over your left shoulder like that
kind of design like you know like
including four of those in a row and
then just a picture of you like drinking
cocoa you know like it won't do as well
because your main audience is there but
doing as well on social media can't come
at the expense of who you want to be
yeah that makes a lot of sense it's
super simple I also want to talk to you
about me doing maybe a branded wine text
comic with me I would love to great hit
up laughs so let's get it done
absolutely awesome nice to meet you nice
to meet you too good luck thank ya I
mean just to build on that for everybody
like this is a common theme and I think
you've seen it already even in the short
time we've been doing tea with Gary be
like people have become absolute slaves
to the engagement and social to what my
fans want and you know there's that
classic you know analogy of like if I
gave my customers what they wanted I
would have made a faster horse instead
of a car like I just really can't
believe that you know I really want to
inspire people to make sure they post
what they want to post even if it
doesn't do as well
photos with me and people like don't do
as well including like my family
just doesn't do as well but I want to
share that so share it it's only one
post you know to put in a different way
for everybody just one post the
algorithm is not going to destroy you
for it
it's just one post no post is gonna
destroy you let's keep it going
especially if it's making you happy hey
Gary how are you I'm well how are you
good hey I'm just getting started here
I've worked with your team and made
these Gary Vee Lego figures
and your team is just so fantastic to
work with man you've got the best of the
best for you
thank you you bet so my question is
about side hustles I have lots of side
hustles I'm an entrepreneur myself of a
musician I do the flip game I've got my
hands and lots of things and the
question is how do you know when there
are too many side missiles is there such
a thing and where do you cut slack to me
once people understand that happiness is
success not financial is success all of
a sudden this question goes completely
away you know because people that have a
ton of side hustles do it cuz they like
it you know eight out of ten two out of
ten think they're gonna find some sort
of like passive income like scheme
that's gonna let them like lay on the
beach and just make money but most
people that have a lot of things going
on are just inherently creative and need
the action absolutely yet you know a lot
of people a lot of people are like wow
Gary B you're so nice you're helping
your dad so much with wine tax Dustin
you know like super cool but the reality
is I need wine texts as much as wine
texts and my dad needs me right I need
that creative outlet like we sent out an
email this morning to a big 300,000
person wine list and like I couldn't
wait to wake up and see what the numbers
look like you know and so like you know
what I really believe that creative
people need a lot of things and you know
it may not maximize your financial
impact it does for me because things
like wine Tech's
allow me to stay focused on vaynermedia
but for some people they may never find
massive financial success but they'll be
happy like playing music flipping stuff
building Legos like like happiness
Jonathan right like you know and I think
if you can make one of those things
you're 80% you can then flirt with the
20% to keep you kind of creatively happy
absolutely yeah maybe 70/30 but but
after that it can get to to spread thing
there's a there's a great football you
know analogy of like if you have two
quarterbacks you have none there's a
great Russian saying that basically
translates to you can't have your ass
two toilets at the same time you know so
there there is the extreme this is all
balance but I do think 70/30 80/20 and
for everybody listening if your core
business is 70% your time 80% of your
time I think you can get away I believe
that I'm a person that is better at my
80% thing vaynermedia because of being
our sports because of wine techs because
of empathy because of the case was still
cause a Gary Vee you know dah dah dah
dah dah dah dah dah
so I think that my 80 acts like 110
instead of my hundred acting like 90 so
I think some sure a lot of us we need
the side hustles to make our core thing
go better absolutely yeah that's well
said I love it you gotta take care
awesome thanks you too appreciated good
morning Jess Murphy good morning Melissa
a hey-zeus Rios what's good brother
just a 11 things Jared young good
morning
Charlie young I don't see you signed up
for wine texts and neither you Bradley
would Charlie young Bradley would I need
to you need to reply right now with your
sign up and not signed up or if you live
in one of those [ __ ] states that we
can't ship to and Dustin's gonna put you
up when you reply let's keep this going
hey Eric hey is this the dr. Garrett
baby show it sure is sir you're gonna
give the dr. Phil a run for his money I
think everything's good
here's the deal here's the question how
can I turn what is usually a one-time
business into a lifetime customer and
here's my business waiting Forrest fan
only started over a hundred years ago in
Detroit my grandfather
first family business was built right at
the close of World War two family still
owns it I moved out to Southern
California I've been here since 15 years
most of my business come from bridal
Expos and my relationship with the
venue's were I've got about 10 venues
that I'm a preferred vendor so that's
where most of my business comes but
usually I see that bride one time
through the course of maybe six months
to a year
I may hear from a bridesmaid a year
later or a sister to do another wedding
but then that's it so I I'm I'm doing
but both flowers and also I'm an
official I'm a licensed minister so I
probably do like this year already I
vote
even with koban 19 I booked about 40
weddings for this year this time and I
have another 10 next year already booked
and I'll probably do about two officiant
services when I meet with the bride she
needs a minister I offer that as a
service as well and then I probably do
about two to three a month but I'd like
to somehow see you know when that once
that weddings over I rarely hear from
them again
and I don't know really what service to
offer that it's funny when you say this
I've been thinking about this exact
business believe it or not so you said
flowers right
yes wedding flowers specialist makes
sense do you know I've been thinking a
lot about what's the top of the funnel
for acquisition is for a man buying
flowers for his wife for Mother's Day
Valentine's Day birthday and I've always
thought wow the wedding industry really
[ __ ] this up the flowers people
obviously a 10 15 20 30 40 50 $100,000
flower execution at a wedding is very
different than a $300 bouquet however
you know if you think of the typical guy
which is a big audience if the person
that's doing flowers for the wedding
literally just looked over at the other
person at the wedding which is the guy
which you know which 8 out of 10 times
I'm sure is 6 out of 10 times is not
involved intimately on the flower part
and said hey buddy do you want to order
a subscription for me that automatically
sends your white flowers on whatever
three or four key occasions anniversary
like there's four times a year between
anniversary of Valentine's eventually
Mother's Day if they go that route and
birthday I've been fascinated by leaving
that free business on the table even if
you took a referral fee and out sourced
it to somebody who did
small thumbs instead of big things got
it there you go
got it even if you took 30% of the if
you roll up on any local floors and said
look let's split it 50/50 I'm gonna
bring you the customer you know how much
habitat costs I want to do percent of
the profit but I I'm there I'm in the
acquisition place
I mean it's by the way back to you know
sisters and things like I think there's
a massive flower subscription business
well on the back of florists and
subscription not one time yeah look
Calvin Knight in the comments this is
genius I just made you that myself guys
don't want to think about this [ __ ] we
Frank yeah so if you told me four times
here you're gonna bang him for 300 bucks
or you know if somebody's 50 bucks or
whatever the number is I'm thrilled
that's the greatest gift that's more
exciting the [ __ ] wedding yeah
because now you're a good guy your
wife's gonna love you or your family's
gonna love you your mom whatever you
that's great I am per normal wedding
you're probably gonna you know
inevitably half the Greenes men or the
father are married and you're like
there's just an there's probably three
it's not one I think if you really play
it hard and don't know I'm up super
douchey but you come off communicative
you're probably signing up three to five
subscriptions by the time you know that
adds up you said 40 yeah right now and
that's just right now I mean that's
that's just here we are April and I had
that even last month because of Coby 19
I've had to reschedule a lot of weddings
so I'm kind of open right now but yeah I
should probably double that by the end
of the year you talk about 80 you talk
about two people on average one
sometimes one sometimes zero sometimes
five depending on the wedding party that
sign up for that subscription let's just
call it 160 people four times a year
it's recurring you might keep you you
want you asked me how do I keep a
customer or create a more than one time
I'm showing you a way to hit him four
times a year in perpetuity that's sounds
great and I like that because as a
floral specialist wedding specialist I'm
not your normal retail store so I order
flowers bring them to my home studio I
designed everything here so I don't
always have flowers in the cooler like a
regular retail
by developing relationship with the
retail business oh that would be awkward
or Eric at scale you eventually realize
that you're besides birthdays and when I
mean there's two times a year that you
can do it yourself
Mother's Day and you know and
Valentine's Day you could control that
and keep all the margin because once you
get the scale and have a thousand people
on your subscription now you have enough
scale to buy both you see where I'm
going right as long as it was as long as
it was local because I'm from the
Southern California Temecula area
because a lot of brides they'll fly in
right now do destination weddings yeah
but if you're outsourcing the
fulfillment you don't have to be local
what you need to do is spend a good
couple months on finding 50 to 500
partners to be the execution and you
keep a margin on top of the execution
even outside yeah I got you now oh you
know literally Rick from Bernardsville
New Jersey flies in for that destination
wedding he's like hey I'm pumped about
this you literally go to google and type
in Burnsville or Sussex County New
Jersey florists you call five of them
Ford are lazy and don't give a [ __ ] the
fifth ones like hell yeah I'll take the
free money you cut the girl and away you
go all the orders go through you so they
don't go around you I love it
that's a great idea that's great well
listen you didn't keep me around for
nothing Eric you don't watch this [ __ ]
for my looks I promise you that bless
you brother thank you man
why you do people just got it like that
listen some people can score 45 in a big
playoff game so people can sing the
national anthem and make you cry other
people can come over the business I see
it's like repetition so what happens
when you do and think and live this for
[ __ ] thirty seven straight years every
second of your life this is what happens
when it's your ethos let's keep it going
hey Gary how's it going I'm well better
how are you I'm
doing good so a little about myself I
spent about seven years in the military
after Spanx and I later transitioned out
and now I'm going to college for
professional and technical
communications I have about three years
left and a lot of my gears and a lot of
my drive is turning towards the social
media communications aspect of what's
going on around in the world and kind of
my question right now is how can I
become a more respectable person in that
industry meaning meaning why do you want
to be respected let's play because I
think you'll see where I'm going so why
do I want to be respected because I want
to be able to work with small clients
large clients and also with you know
people that I can help I want to be able
to help others and help you want to
build your business and you think the
exact matters yes so I think that's
right
I just wanted to hear you say it I think
the way you do it is you do three to
five things and services and deals for
free in return for the endorsement and
the reviews on Yelp or Google reviews or
you know wherever that may sit and I
think you'd only do it for free with
people that bring you the most value for
their voice they say you know just do it
for somebody nobody's ever heard of
because you know Karen from Temecula you
can just you know it's not gonna drive
you through the roof so I think doing
free work for people that have clout
that their endorsement on your website
or your social you know if someone lands
on your social media and the profile
says you know Oprah says you know better
is [ __ ] amazing at snapchat whoa
that's gonna [ __ ] matter yeah I agree
and I have and it's something that I'm
trying to build of course as you and as
you said I'm seriously writing this down
because I have that mindset that if I
don't write it down it'll be gone
forever and I'm also trying to create
respect respect is earned yes
right so we have a huge lead right now
for vaynermedia why because the person
hired somebody and that person said I
worked with Boehner in the past
and they're awesome you know it's just
the reps the problem is when you're at
zero for example speaking you know my
first speaking gig was paid for because
I'm even know what existed public
speaking but after that I did about 8 to
12 to 15 for free because I wanted to
get the reps I paid for my travel uh
everyone said Kerry I want to be a
motivational speaker like I'm not a
motivational speaker first I always play
that game with them but I'm like look if
you want to be a public speaker one of
the best ways to do that is to speak for
free at first it's date Chappell and
Chris Rock and Eddie Murphy played
[ __ ] [ __ ] clubs for $2 or a free beer
or free cuz he needed the reps you know
you know Taylor Swift played the [ __ ]
local you know thing at 14 years old for
free like everyone's like I just don't
understand how people don't understand
this like you need to know your worth
don't do [ __ ] for free only said by
people who aren't winning like you know
do some work for free to get the to get
the quotes to get the reputation okay
problem is the most people that don't
want to do it for free
realize that the works not good enough
to create word-of-mouth if you actually
believe you were great you would always
do shipper free I always do shipper free
because I know exactly what happens
after the fact it's true that's why
we're doing this right that's right god
I already think they need very so much
free work quotes you know listen if
somebody's willing to pay you great but
at first it's hard you know going from
zero to one is hard free is usually the
unlock it's a dirty word to a lot not to
me okay absolutely Gary thank you so
much you got a provided by and by the
way for everybody's gonna go down the
three paths have you just got inspired
get prepared to get screwed you do a
bunch of good work for somebody and
they're like they don't like to work and
they don't give you a quote and then
you're like [ __ ] Gary [ __ ] me up I
thought I was gonna get the quote from
this you have to realize that one or two
quotes makes up for the six people that
[ __ ] you if you're in business you gotta
get ready to be [ __ ] look at this deer
the deer knows deers eating that [ __ ]
for free free works in nature and in
business that's
keep doing hey how are you - can you
hear me okay yeah I can okay um first
thing I just wanted to say thank you for
everything do we know that the online
space is kind of the Wawa West so good
people that are really brick an8 okay in
my book
thank you for my question it's it's a
little over which is what I wanted to
bring it here and that is the fact I
have been in business for about eight
years now yeah I have been fourteen
different industries online and I keep
running into the same issue where I know
it doesn't let's give this reset you
can't wait to get Jessica back she's
awesome but let's get a reset thank you
let me say hello well doesn't get setup
boxy nerteaux is good to see you thank
you for always being here
Gabrielle Rodriguez I appreciate you
back the nation what is good thirty
teams I do like the dirty T t-shirt I do
like that real quick
wine Tex calm today huge opera
Chardonnay it is summer season if that
if you're on the East Coast this weekend
was amazing really excited about today
big-time big-time Chardonnay white
bernini big-time white burgundy monster
score Forbes magazine went nuts for it
it's going to be a big big big big big
big big offer a lot of you are not
training enough white wine and a lot of
you have been asking me really today's
wine is because I'm listening to the
streets tons of red wine offerings
people have been complaining that's the
only way to put it so monster red
monster white wine offering today let's
keep it going
Oh Jess okay we're back all right for
businesses for businesses you always
come into the same place which is having
a bigger vision but at the same time
it's one of those things that to
accomplish the vision is going to take
work and even if it takes five or ten
years it puts me in the fear of success
with it of okay if it works now what now
I would be like close to 40 and I
achieve like the thing I put on the
pedal stool this whole time or the fear
of failure where if you do this one
thing doesn't mean it's gonna work like
everything else and if you really lean
into that and go forward with it and it
doesn't work like holy crap so it's like
I don't show it looks yeah I got it yeah
no actually you are putting people on a
pedestal you're because what you're
worried about is the judgment when it
loses pretty much yeah you actually are
putting people on a pedestal so it's
like I find do you ever do you have a
good you have a good sense of whose
opinion you most worried about like who
would be like oh you suck like when I
say like the person who says like you're
a failure or you lost or I'm
disappointing you like who comes up
first
probably like parent type of situation
which is weird cuz I do it I've done
everything so that's good that means
you're you're super close that means you
just need to realize you're still there
just because you did 18 things the other
way this 19 thing is [ __ ] you up
listen I've been very consistent with
this and I think you know this I'm
obsessed with people falling in love
with using push back negativity the dirt
all of it cuz it works because once
you're not that means you're not scared
this is one humongous game of fear
but it doesn't show in anything else
like I lose all the time in business
it's just normal you put something out
you're like you something bye-bye
I had no fear in life but I was scared
to kiss girls in like junior high and
high school like great I'm sure you like
things pop up in lots of places like I'm
with you like lots of you know I'm
insane
in sports like I punched my brother I
want to hurt you literally literally
want to hurt people literally my hope
when I play sports against people is
they become injured like I'm being
really serious with you like in my brain
in that moment in that context I
desperately want that person to be hurt
in life that is not who I am in real
life of course it doesn't show up in
other places we act different in
different circumstances the end there
are people who have [ __ ] parents who are
than remarkable parents vice versa you
know people who have incredible work
ethic at work who can't spend two
minutes putting up a sign in a building
you know like like of course it doesn't
show up in other places overnight and
then no matter what it's like leaned
back to all the things that are
comfortable in building at judgement
people worry about judgment people put
other people's opinions on pedestals
over their own happiness so do the thing
because what ends up happening is regret
and regrets suck [ __ ] and then lack of
accountability now you're moping around
your 60s 70s and 80s and you're bitter
and you're blaming everybody but
yourself
ah and then parents died and you're
sitting there for another 25 years
and just it's just what I don't want for
people it's a trap the number one thing
that everybody can do for their parents
and themselves is to live their life on
their own two feet and on their own
decisions so would you say yeah my best
option in this it's like the topics I
want to talk about because I'd like
trickled them in two bit like anything
that's a personal brand I can trickle it
in because it's about mental health and
um topics like that
and they do well like yes Dustin just
like throw myself in the water so to
speak of just like you know what for 30
days just talk about yes I was I was
scared to ride a bike because I don't
want to skin my knees and then I did I
was scared to swim I didn't swim until I
was like nine or something like that and
then I just jumped in the pool cuz my
sister started swimming and that was
unacceptable that my younger sister
started before me like yes everything's
scary until it's not it's all boogie
monsters it's all fake mm-hmm it's all
[ __ ] wrong it's all of it
it's all fake just go do question for
you is there any chance is there any
chance of coming in and seeing your like
shadowing your marketing team for the
day and then I'm happy to do work for
another does a trade yeah why me what
you don't need to give back but you can
definitely hit up Dustin right now and
we'll set up three four out yes you can
you can shadow for today once that day
comes who knows that might be early next
year whenever back but I'm for it
you got it Jess you ask you get you're
welcome Big Ups swing for the ring
appreciate you
thanks
here with us Sam space 81 kara
Carrington it really is true Karen
everything is scary until it's not like
it's just really real let's keep it
going hey Megan hey Gary how are you
good good um first of all I just want to
say thank you so much for everything
you're doing I've been listening to you
for a while like you really changed my
life you bring so much positivity so I
just from the bottom of my heart I just
wanted to say thank you I'd really
appreciate everything you're welcome so
let me just give you a little bit of a
background I'm an ER physician but I'm
also a photographer I've been doing
photography actually since med school
which is ironic a little bit but it's
mostly travel stuff I started a travel
blog maybe three or four years ago and
then over the past two years I've had
some successes you know I've been part
of some galleries some shows things like
that so it's been great but really when
when kovat started I began to document
like my journey as an ER physician and a
photographer on the front lines
I've been putting it up on the blog and
for the first time ever I got some like
traction on my work you know people
interested like people reaching out to
me bloggers and podcasters and things
like that so I'm very grateful for that
I've been kind of riding this wave of
success but my question is really you
know I want to reach out more and kind
of present this project and put it out
there but my question is you know I know
you always talk about bring value and I
feel as a photographer as a creator
sometimes it's really hard to you know
reach out and don't look like you're
just pushing your content I want to be
able to provide value but I just don't
know how to do it in terms of you know
I've been you know work itself being
well the work itself is the value if
you're asking when you're reaching out
you know there's a couple ways it
depends on who you're reaching out to
for what I mean you're more than welcome
to reach out to people you admire or
want to do business with and say hey I
want to give you I want to you know I'd
love to do some photography for free
let me you know let me know if you're
interested here's some check out my
profile for work I mean that's immediate
value that you're bringing now I get
asked fifty to five hundred times a day
for people to do free work and 99.9999%
time I say no because when you're in a
place where people want to get access or
something from you they're gonna offer
that and eventually it doesn't become as
valuable you know Wendy Rock offered to
do a free film it was super valuable to
me now there's five thousand of those
it's just supply and demand and that's
okay
but there's plenty of people who will
take you up on it and III think asking
is okay sometimes people blend my advice
or I don't even think I give advice to
be frank it's funny even the way that
just came out I don't like it
I think people blend my thoughts my
hypotheses my opinions and think it's
absolutely every time it's actually why
real Jab Jab Jab right hook you know
it's sometimes it's okay to ask you know
not in you don't need to blend it every
time and the value is the work so and
you can always offer to do some work for
free yeah I guess just like I always
wonder because I feel like you know with
the type of photography that I do it's
more I know how to code like you know
documentary or whatever you know it's I
always just felt like I understand were
you know with the content like it makes
sense to me especially if you're talking
about frontline or like there's gonna be
like emotional pictures of people in
moments that capture pipe that
photography is well established we all
know that photography I guess the
question is what would be your dream
scenario doing photography full-time and
sustaining your life I assume right I'm
not really sure you know kind of I think
being a physician is part of your
identity
after you there's so much so I think in
the end I you know I I do want to keep
doing that you know before before the
whole cover thing started when I I never
really blended the two it was always
like you know oh I could do something on
the side like workshops and things like
that and now do you think you can blend
the two in perpetuity or do you think
this is a moment in time you know it's
funny because I started to think about
that the other day I was like you know
because obviously the pandemic
it's not gonna last forever but I did
start thinking about it I was like you
know this is something that I could
actually continue doing I think so too
I think so too and you know just like
firefighters you know after 9/11 you
know I think this has been you know so
much devastation from this but one of
the great things is the appreciation
level for nurses and physicians and
doctors will now never be the same for
next 20 years minimum ly there's so much
gratitude collective gratitude for the
men and women and heroes that are at the
front lines of this enormous ly
difficult pandemic and so I think that
because of that that even gives you more
permission to keep going with this you
know I think that if I'm you I'm putting
out your work everywhere so it's not
just Instagram I be you have a Pinterest
account posted there Twitter Facebook
making collages against popular songs on
tik-tok I think you need to put yourself
in a position the same way that people
are reaching out to you right now off of
a small exposure base you could make one
collage against one epic song that's
popping on tick-tock right now and it
could catch four million views the right
13 views and then it might give you the
leverage to do it forever see you got a
really strikes going this time this is
the highest emotion against those photos
so you need to be everywhere and you
need like every photo you took you know
I know you're probably like every other
artist oh this one's not as good this
one's not as good I want all of them out
all of them maybe you saved the best
ones in your opinion for your Instagram
feed but everywhere else stories
Facebook Twitter every piece of content
goes out the photo that you think is
mundane might be the photo that changes
your life it's yeah that's exactly how
you say it actually we're very
self-critical in in general so insane
yeah all right good luck thank you do it
all right you know and that advice is
for everybody to Universal like say no
for the audience is the greatest mistake
that creators make it's their own
insecurities manifesting I love
perfectionist yeah you don't get a need
to be perfect you mean
you're scared let's keep it going hey
Ernie what's good how are you I'm good
I'm well thanks for having me on the
show
I love the content that you put out and
yeah just thanks for everything that you
do for us are you from Texas right now
so a little a little backstory I have
pretty much played at the high level of
basketball my whole life women's
basketball played in Oklahoma best
player in Oklahoma McDonald's
all-american played here at UT
University of Texas
seven years overseas so I am trying I
want to be happy I want to do what makes
me happy so I would love nothing more
than to build a career as a skilled
coach working with AAU teams working
with big camps yep new therapist that
helps accelerate injuries pretty fast
being a speaker in a mentor to young
athletes especially female athletes
because I think of course I'm struggling
to figure out how to build traction and
brand I guess of my sports training
business - okay I got you I got you
it's a same old thing it's no different
than the gentleman a couple of calls ago
I think you know given your
relationships
I'm sure there's teammates that went on
to the WNBA or coaches that went to this
or that miss you've got a rolodex you
know McDonald's all-american you've got
relationships you've got you've got
relationships I think again I think you
go and document you know once we get
back to some normalcy I think I think
you hit up every [ __ ] person you know
and you offer your services for free at
a camp or minimum wage or be an intern
you being an intern at at you know at
you know the Connecticut coaches Geno's
camp right let's say he has a camp I
don't I don't know but you being an
intern there and
you get you would pay hid in my mind you
should pay him for the ability to make
all that content that's co-signing
against the best program in the nation
which you then post everywhere just like
the last woman you know how this works
one Hine and especially off the
devastating tragedy Gigi and Kobe's
passing like there's so much more
attention to young women's basketball
right now right just like all you need
is one one high net worth individual to
like to hire you to have you train their
daughter to you know like just want to
start a business with you this is all
about content across all the platforms
that leads to business development
you are one epic tick tock video away
from everything you want yet I say it
every morning every afternoon every
evening and when you're so lucky to have
something like basketball skills which
is so visual for the world we now live
in like the [ __ ] I do is not visual I
have to articulate it you know business
operations isn't visual right no making
a full court shot that gets 40 million
views on tick-tock is real you you're
gifted you have the best platform off
the most cultural thing basketball
women's like Jesus like your sit like
you couldn't have picked a better time
to be alive I just need you to put out
40 pieces of content a day and
99.999999% of people aren't even close
they just can't get there okay but it
will lead to everything you want you put
your email you put your email in your
all your accounts and [ __ ] will just
happen if you make 40 to 50 [ __ ]
videos and pictures a day three per tick
tock three main post four main posts on
Instagram 13 stories 5 tweets like this
is real [ __ ] coach like like back you
know what's so funny I love talking to
coaches and like people that know their
craft
you know like you know like inevitably
anis or somebody that you know there's
gonna be 11 it's gonna be like I'm gonna
be in the WNBA and you know she's
[ __ ] not working you know she's not
up you already know she's finished right
that's how I view this with content okay
like it's simple my little guy loves
basketball he's about to turn eight all
I'm doing is making him working with his
left hand and like yeah and like I know
that's gonna pay dividends I also know
his genetics aren't sending him anywhere
close to the NBA but he's gonna hurt
some people and pick up basketball and
he's gonna be happy that left was
developed that's the work yeah
the Euro step that he does perfectly
which is blows my mind is the work okay
you need to do the work on the content
you're literally one piece of content
away from everything you want to happen
okay it's real so you got to make
content about you know here's your
everything you know number one mistake
with the way people hold the basketball
15 different piece of content about left
hands for righties 50 like if you've got
a daughter that you want to be in the
WNBA and she's three and you're not
tying her right hand behind her back you
[ __ ] up that's the video that could
change your life you understand yeah 100
500 free-throws a day what 500
free-throws day and then you go outside
set up your phone you don't want Maddie
Rock and take 500 [ __ ] free-throws
and then you come home and you Google
how do i edit a video and then you
[ __ ] speed it up so it doesn't take
[ __ ] forever because five hundreds
gonna take a minute and now you got a
video of you putting 500 [ __ ]
free-throws up for two minutes and 30
seconds against a rowdy rich song that
[ __ ] goes okay the work yeah you know
90% of the people don't post post to
content that I want because they're
insecure and they're worried about
judgment but another 90 percent overlaid
over that not in addition because
there's only a hundred percent
they don't do it cuz they don't actually
want to put in the work it's [ __ ]
work I think it's I think it's the fear
for me like for for for the last couple
years it's I've been on and off with the
content and thinking about it too much
too much I'm to the point I'm like
whatever I just want
I want to be consistent and put it out
and stop worrying about what people
think correct who cares if you have four
followers who cares that you got one
like we all did at first yeah and when
they come at you you're like what did
you do [ __ ] you like what what's your
handle because a lot of people are
asking what's your handle at a hoops
performance so easiest yep
a hoops mm-hmm he hoops performance on
Instagram YouTube at Coach Ernie
Williams have you thought about coach
Ernie Williams for for Instagram no I
think people relate more with humans
okay I'd rather you you know I think you
should change it to to you and then just
put the app whose performance in your
bio so it's linked out of oh I think
that would be a better structure people
connect more with humans
I believe that high net-worth woman man
is gonna hire you or give you that break
more because it's you the human than a
hoops performance and and the other
thing that lets you do is like it lets
you make a video of you having a Slurpee
and then telling the kids like yo you
don't have to [ __ ] be perfect every
minute this [ __ ] little slushy
[ __ ] helped me cuz you know like you
know like you know what I mean like it
lets you be more human okay I like it
opens up more content you're welcome
back any tick-tock I'm telling you go on
tick-tock type in basketball in search
watch 550 videos over two hours and
start making content okay if [ __ ]
kills on tick-tock and do and do like
some women empowerment [ __ ] like get one
of your like you know brothers best
friends a guy and let and play among 101
and [ __ ] destroy him chop up that
video and like what [ __ ] will kill Ernie
people don't get how much better like
guys are solutions are [ __ ] stupid
guys don't realize they can't beat at
all [ __ ] about McDonald's
all-american
in one-on-one they think they can
because they're on that [ __ ] guy
girl things you would [ __ ] destroy
every friend I've got you know what I
mean
put that [ __ ] out that will get women
like that's the [ __ ] good [ __ ] you
know yeah thank you
you got it some good stuff I think that
helped a lot of people that you know was
Nishi to her but I think a lot of you
needed to hear that
let's keep it going hi ginger how are
you I'm well how are you a huge
supporter and I just can't thank you
enough I love your team I love your
community your Twitter community
I am so my question first is how do I go
deeper but also wider on my Instagram
after already experiencing some success
can you hear me okay very well
my my ear just itched okay so long story
that story so I do pharmaceutical sales
by day and I've been doing it for a very
long time I have done more cold calls
than anybody on earth fenced I really
love talking to people and so six years
ago I decided I had a child I was like
you know what I'm gonna pick up a camera
I'm gonna learn photography it became
very simple for me um or very basic you
know just learning how to use the camera
I started doing it every single day I
became obsessed with my craft I learned
how to do it very well
long story short got into kids fashion
started blogging for a magazine and
started you know just getting noticed
and it felt really good it's like wow
I'm doing good in my craft and
eventually that helps me learn how to
study what people want and study brands
and really
don't in on you know how to how to
attention half basically which is great
right so I've been doing that but I
don't know how to kind of build on that
meaning how do you define building more
attention hacking so you get more
awareness or convert it into something
how do you define build I want to
convert it into something well what do
you want to sell that's the thing I
don't I don't know I don't good so don't
don't sell yeah don't sell and yeah
don't sell until you have something to
sell yeah like I'm I'm I'm honestly
really happy with what I'm doing I love
again I love the community I love the
people I'm obsessed with with connecting
and I see it I see it in my Twitter I
see it yeah that's that's good me too
I had a wine store that I was focused on
when I was building my six years of
connecting asking for nothing first time
I had it took me years before there was
anything I asked her and that was an $11
book called crush it which oh by the way
[ __ ] changed unlimited people's lives
because they've learned from reading
unlike me and so like like you know this
because we engage so much like what like
I'm super proud of wine text it's
literally the best way to buy wine in
America I really genuinely believe that
it's super fun when you have something
to sell
you know like empathy wines is literally
the best $20 I really believe that I
like you know I really felt feel great
about that yeah and if there's there's
no pressure because you don't like where
I'm at I'm having I'm honestly having so
much fun because it's almost like a
challenge like okay who can i hack and
like I have to say it but when last year
Will Smith reposted one of my photos
which I was blown away because who does
that
so I move in you you reposted one of my
photos and you know it's just it it the
validation of just and it's not a
cheater no you're you're a salesperson
yeah
you love the game I do that's amazing me
too i do you understand how happy i get
when i find a $12 mug at a garage sale
for 25 cents it's more exciting for me
than landing a 5 million dollar deal for
vaynermedia
I swear on the Jets my children and
everything that I only eat my chemicals
are more excited yeah you like the idea
of strategy of how am I gonna get Will
Smith and Gary to retweet you like that
there's nothing wrong with that that's
amazing you love your process it's
probably why you're so successful at
pharmaceutical sales you love your
process yeah I don't think you have to
have a right hook from social I also
think you're an extremely young woman
who may decide to start a raspberry farm
in 17 years and then that's what it
converts into yeah well you're not just
making my brother double double double
listen to me
ginger listen to me listen me we're
extremely young yeah in 17 years were
[ __ ] sixty-one like I just I don't
know how people don't understand that
like I'm gonna be [ __ ] hustling my
face off at 78 I'm gonna be making
empires at 70 I'm gonna be super bowl's
I'm gonna be you know buying countries
and changing the name like I'm [ __ ]
goin for it like what are we doing here
I know and I and I want to encourage
people like you know when you're
scrolling on social media and you kind
of just see the same like you know I
want more I don't want to just show take
more what I did because I feel like I'm
excluding people I don't want people to
feel like oh look what she did and how
am I getting supposed to live up to that
I had no I worked from ginger ginger
ginger ginger don't even take yourself
that serious yeah humility is the unlock
here good news
nobody's nobody's thinking that about
you when you realize you're the most
special and you're not special at all
[ __ ] gets really good yeah don't let
your ego have that combo with you nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you ginger you're
right no you're right
seriously yeah and that's that's that's
the freedom that's that's where it is
you once you realize a person like with
you live up to you it's a piece of cake
from millions and it's impossible for
other millions yeah do you understand
yeah don't go into that game so I mean I
think I'm gonna I think I'm gonna win
the whole [ __ ] thing and I still know
that nobody gives a [ __ ] yeah I know I'm
with you knowing as well there's
something deep down there and I want to
drag it out and I don't and I'm precious
process problems just keep going just
keep experimenting just keep putting
myself out there and see what ends up
happening ginger if we have a lot of
similarities I think we do like you
start becoming better at giving yeah I
need this hour every morning I got a lot
of [ __ ] going on yeah but but I've
gotten to practice of giving so I need
to do this you know it just becomes your
it almost becomes like brushing your
teeth and taking a shower yeah second
nature yeah it's a part of nature
yeah I mean it's it's super fun to like
realize you're doing something well and
like people are you know when you came
on here a ton of people in the community
were like yeah but just but just just
remember if you ground yourself in like
that one little insight to like how are
they going to live up to it you're
you're miss playing that you're
listening to a couple people's feedback
and more importantly you're allowing
yourself to put yourself on a pedestal
and that becomes a vulnerability yeah
myself I think I try to build on where I
got you know myself and then I'm sure
you're you're at you're at your best
when you like the process yeah you just
are lucky the way I'm lucky and there's
nothing else to say then luck that the
process of making the deal or closing
the thing is the process we like a lot
of people hate that press
us so our process happens to have
financial success behind it but that's a
very different thing than happiness yeah
and so you need to realize it is that
process that you love and then that puts
you in a really good spot my process is
I've found a love for promoting people I
call myself a connector because I have
some the most success is when I connect
with someone that connects to somebody
else and when I put them both together
not by my doing but because of like you
call serendipity things happen magic
happens good leads to good bad leads to
bad yeah people in this comment section
right now some of them are really good
and good things will happen some of them
are not as good and bad things will
happen like this simple yeah like super
[ __ ] cynicism anger negativity has at
times short term success which always
falls apart like a cheap [ __ ] chair
it's hard to be good and optimistic and
positive it's easy it's easy to be
cynical and negative and dark that's a
piece of [ __ ] cake that person soft
simple soft [ __ ] soft it's hard to be
good yeah and it's cool thank you so
much
you got it thank you you check here
Dustin yes sir let's do some PSAs
there's a lot of new people in here one
if you want to get on the show
it is best to sign up for my text
community where we're sending out all
sorts of stuff if you're watching right
now in the US and Canada please hit up
to one two nine three one five seven
three one if you send in your question
with hashtag tea with Gary B but all you
should be signing up for this anyway
that's big so for everybody that's new
today Dan Weaver actually everyone in
the comments put reply right now with
the number of days you've been watching
this obviously some it's been going
for about a month or so so some of you
may not recall it's going on for long in
a month oh we been doing this March 23rd
first day
Brooke reply with up how many days
you've been watching cuz yeah Eddie
Eddie claros one day love that darn out
day to Cove in 19 Philly with a bag 23
days I appreciate that real chef Mikey
I've watched for last three weeks texted
90 times Mikey would try and Brussels we
really are trying the other way to get
your question on is to use the hashtag T
with Gary B in Twitter for all the
international people doesn't tell the
team we want some international love
tomorrow
international and everybody's watching
right now squeeze chute this share it on
Twitter Gary bees my handle there always
gives you a better chance of catching
our attention when you screen shoot the
show mm-hmm
everyone loved the the florists one that
I did yeah yes you have the luxury of
now being around me like the ability for
me to go into idea to face is so heavy
you need to do a little bit yeah there I
wonder if I should do a whole show just
on like rapid-fire tell me the business
tell me what you want to happen cuz
that's what you know the you know my two
core strengths are mindset you know just
optimism positivity practicality like
everything in the brain but then I also
have like actual business strategies
which you know tend to come out less
because of the nature of the format
which is why I always tell people watch
what I do not what I say it's very easy
for me to give the 40 pieces of content
advice you know so anyway what else does
he had a good weekend yeah good
just worked and then oh I did a couple
people have been hitting him you know to
do their podcast so I've been doing that
for them too I love that that was cool
I'm sure you're busy with that um hope
you have a good weekend alright
everybody thank you so much for uh
excuse me
um everybody thank you for so much for
watching we'll be back tomorrow I'm
really looking forward to that key share
the show I feel like a lot of people
could get a lot of value from this
notice in the comments a lot of people
talking about thank you Scott
Janssen first time watching Jennifer
Dalton thank you so much
I think I think a lot of people getting
value from this and I think a lot of
people don't know about it I think a lot
of people in your community don't know
about it I think a lot of people in your
community don't I certainly love me cuz
I'm too aggressive in a single video
that they saw on Instagram or said
something about college and they've got
their feelings hurt but I would love
that you can share this screenshot
Facebook groups Facebook your email
lists your social media wouldn't mean
the world to me the new and really fun
campaign tomorrow where if people yes
doesn't um since we're not assist all
your all in challenges over
I'm not should I not play that video and
I don't play the video yeah I think we
announce the winner today oh okay cool
somebody peed 10 bucks bro $10 I'll be
crazy I think we raised almost a half a
million dollars it's amazing in a really
short time yeah it's really cool how
much uh how much is the Owen challenge
up to we have raised 31 million dollars
it's crazy I appreciate all of you so
much appreciate all the support and
thank you giant the florist idea was a
good one
thank you for donating to the åland
challenge everybody and thank you
everybody to sign up for my text I'm
really excited about I'm really enjoying
it today's today's um today's offer is
really gangster like legit legit [ __ ] so
thank you so much and we will talk to
you soon
if you sign up for white X right now
I've got like two minutes before my next
meeting
can me up with the confirmation screen
on Twitter that the following retweet
you thanks for watching guys take care